Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go next to where do we want to go next?
How about.
What about Sid?
From Ohio, Sid, you're on the air
Speaker 3: and you're watching your show.
Yeah, I was wondering, what do you think about
the the right and the left?
All media like young Turks and some other
news.
It seems like they spent a lot of trancelike,
if not conspiracy, false news.
And I know the right like Fox.
And you had some like Breitbart to do it on
purpose.
What do you think?
Do you think the left also does it on purpose?
Speaker 1: What fake news did the Young Turks
spread?
Speaker 3: Well, the young Turks, they constantly
promote, like Bernie Sanders as the IT Miss
Reno, he will, if he would have won the probably
would not have been great for the left.
You know, like like they focus on Ocasio Cortez
to focus on certain candidates.
And almost like when the promotional, you
know, promotional thing for them like
Speaker 1: that, how how is that fake news?
Speaker 3: Well, they're not being fair to
the watchers to really give them like a good
idea of who these candidates are.
They focus on certain policies like like and
specifically like.
The one fake news I do remember is one of
the the popular girl see during a debate was
talking about.
Hold on a second.
Speaker 1: Well, let's just back up just a
little bit, OK?
OK, who?
The popular girl.
What are you saying?
Speaker 3: Sorry, I don't remember her name,
but she she's one of the main.
Speaker 1: You're saying one of the hosts
of the Young Turks, are you talking about
and.
Speaker 3: Yes, yes.
Ana.
Yeah.
Yeah that's ok.
OK, ok.
So Ana was in a debate with Tommy Leron and
I was watching and she said that how the unemployment
rate in America, even though it went down
during Trump, it actually went up for qualified
like like people who have a college degree
but actually were working like minimum wage
jobs.
So it actually fell.
And I when I checked the facts on that, that
was wrong.
That did not happen.
Now, that was
Speaker 1: that Politiken, right?
That was that Politiken know.
OK, so I don't know the statistic, but if
I said it something that was wrong, that's
not fake news.
That sounds like she was mistaken.
Fake news would be like if I say Hillary Clinton
gave birth to an alien baby like that would
be fake news.
Being wrong about an unemployment rate isn't
fake news.
And it also wasn't on the Young Turks.
It sounds like it was in the middle of a debate.
Right?
Speaker 3: Right.
But it just seems like the vibe that I get
from young Turks, like they're heavily, heavily
biased.
Like you don't seem like you're going to listen
to you.
You seem like somebody who's reporting objective
journalism.
Speaker 1: Listen, I think I'm as biased as
the young.
We're all doing opinion shows, OK?
So I think that this is a media illiterate.
We're all doing opinion shows.
It's possible that what you're saying is your
opinions differ from those on the Young Turks
where like the Young Turks was too pro Bernie
for you or to pro AOC for you.
But I, I don't think we're all doing opinion
programs.
So I would recalibrate your critique.
Maybe maybe what you mean is you don't agree
politically with the Young Turks.
Is that maybe what you're saying?
Speaker 2: I feel like I feel like they don't
Speaker 3: like like here's the thing, like
if you watch Fox, like they might like like
I'm not I'm a Democrat myself, but I feel
like if you watch Fox, like you might get
a better highlight of what the represented
like like the downfall of of representative.
Like we can go down the list of Bernie and
you'll see and how the support might support
some of the wrong things.
But you're not going to hear that on the Internet
like they will.
They will only say good things about them.
Speaker 1: OK, I don't know whether that's
true or not, because I don't I don't watch
any of these shows, you know, on my program.
I at least try to give you like, for example,
when I talk about Medicare for all I say,
Medicare for all could be a great way to organize
health care.
Here's all the great things about it.
Here's some that are question marks.
And here's three other ways we could organize
health care like I'm making that effort.
The counter, though, would be do you think
you heard about the downsides of Donald Trump
on Fox News?
Speaker 3: There are a few feels like Democratic,
like the guy who hosted the debate, like he
would be like hard on the other guy who quit
Fox.
He was also like going hard on him.
But there are very few who say.
Speaker 1: So I think the issue here is the
young Turks on my show and Sam Cedar's show
we are opinion programs and we don't hide
that.
The problem on Fox is they present opinion
as if it's news and that's a real problem.
So that's why I think your example is a false
equivalency.
Speaker 3: Oh, well, I thought that when the
fox when they got sued, they they said that
their piece is an opinion piece.
That's the thing they had, that it's not a
reliable news, because right
Speaker 1: now that's that's a legal defense
that they use.
But what FOX is notorious for doing is deliberately
blurring the lines between what is news and
news and opinion.
This is a big conversation about media literacy.
I think it's really great that you're thinking
about these things.
I think maybe if you had maybe a slightly
more sophisticated understanding of some of
these media literacy issues, your analysis
would be even better, I think is the way I
would put a positive spin on it.
Speaker 2: OK.
All right.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, thank you
for the call.
I mean, listen, it's great that people are
even he he's misinformed about the facts and
lacks some understanding.
But the fact that he's thinking about this
stuff is more than can be said for a lot of
people.
That's that.
That's for sure.
All right.
Thanks, everybody.
I really appreciate everybody who called in
today.
We're out of time for today, but we will take
more calls again in the future.
And we're going to be right back with more
show right after this.